I wonder what your connection was to
this material because I wonder if you
were sitting there like yes finally I
can make my Abscam movie so it's so it's
so how did this develop I think it
really for me began with Amy and
Christian on the movie called The
Fighter and Mark Wahlberg and Melissa
Leo and the sisters in that picture
which to me was I'd written silver
linings before that but that was where I
really discovered this world of
characters that I loved and I said I
think I can keep making movies in this
world I very much love it with the salt
of the earth instinctive people who are
trying to survive and silver linings
then became another kind of chapter of
that for me and then this the characters
just jumped out at me and I found myself
talking to Bradley was in the cutting
room of silver linings and I talked him
about it I talked to Christian in his
back yard about it and what we seized
upon was the the larger notion of of
people reinventing themselves of how
people have passion and what an artist
he was almost like a he was almost like
a theater director and these were all
members of the company and how everybody
everywhere has to sort of create itself
that they believe in and then certain
points that has to change
so these were the ideas that we were
talking about a great deal of fun
playing both I really loved playing
Dickie I really loved playing them of
and you know both both based on real
characters I'm with this one you know
more distant from the the actual man who
you know was hired by the FBI but I
think you know the the the very original
script was more like a historical drama
right it was more of a sort of a plot
oriented point and then what David was
talking about you know I remember
walking around my back garden and we
were talking about well what do we like
about this and it was always about this
this notion of reinvention of yourself
and being born into circumstances that
have nothing to do and no choice of
yours and and everybody's desire if it's
not what you want you know to be able to
change yourself and to reinvent yourself
and and the sense of performance so in
since yes very much about the do with
you know acting as well and if you're
gonna do it you're gonna believe it
yourself your as and as a conman you
know you have to believe it
you can't just it's not enough that the
other people believe it you have to be
believing it yourself you know as an
actor if you're invested you're always
going to kind of be wounded by your
character in some way and you try to you
know drive a certain amount of distance
between your life and your character's
life but they bleed in between and and
definitely I could feel sort of the cost
of reinvention and sort of the hustle
that we play on ourselves and the lies
that we tell ourselves in order to
reinvent means you have to leave
something behind and sometimes if you
reinvent and you don't actually deal
with the shed then you end up with the
[ __ ] you know and so that's sort of
where Edith finds herself when she's
confronted with the truth and and so she
has to as she so brilliantly says
sometimes all you have is some I won't
swear but toxic messed up choices so
that's kind of worry defines herself and
no truer words are ever spoken to eat it
than those words from Roslin and then
there's Roslin who blows up a microwave
and consorts with gangsters and yes
she's she's young and she's naive and I
think that people can be manipulative I
think some people can be manipulative
without realizing it and and and some
people can be manipulative by saying I'm
going to IM manipulating this situation
but it's only to do the right thing it's
to get it she she believes that divorce
is wrong and she believes wholeheartedly
that she and Irving shouldn't be
together
and so she by imprisoning him she's
doing the right thing and by dangling
her son his son that is her version of
forcing him to do the right thing and
you know when everybody is afraid of the
Mafia she said thinks this is a perfect
opportunity to ruin Irv's night to get
back at him because he deserves it so
her thought process I think the the the
one line that kind of sums up
laughing it was when we were having an
argument in the bedroom and I was
packing up to go to Miami to run away
with a mafia member and take his son
with me and I said and she said why
can't you just be happy for me really
makes it very clear that she's how can
you be mad at her she's so clueless
because you know and I read the script
and we had you know all of her actions
and the most exciting part was David and
I coming up with why are they that way
why is she this way that seemed right
there's that one which I mean well that
we changed everything there was that
morning yes and there was that there was
this very very crucial plot point which
David quite rightly he said you know and
I don't like that anymore and so we went
to sat in a bedroom for you know 15
minutes and said what are we gonna do
and it ends up being that fantastic same
way you get you get of going in and
having a go at hub because boyfriend
just put a bag over his head and it's
trying to kill him and then the scene
ends with him thanking her doing that
exactly symmetry no yeah all his movies
have that beautiful combination the
dance between comedy and drama and the
the magical moments of humor and and and
utter loss and you know III you know
that's all over all of his films and
it's certainly here in this movie you
know one second you're laughing
hopefully in the next minute your heart
is breaking for these people they're
rich and they're complicated and they're
hilarious hopefully and more than
anything they're a bit magical you know
there's a little lot of magical moments
in this movie that are all because of
you know the way that he sees the world
I think well first of all I've never
viewed it as a comedy even even if
people do consider just that you can't
play comedy anyway so my part all I can
do is focus on the truth and work every
day to make those truths interesting and
unbelievable and that's that those are
my parameters I know the few times you
come in to either you know I mean to me
because because for comedy you're
playing for
laughs I to me you know we just we just
did it truthfully and that ends up being
funny because people are funny
situations are funny you know but to me
it's it's it's whatever the hell you
want to call it but I I would say
there's there's a lot of funniness
within it but you know people every
single one of you out there you go a
hell of a lot of funny stuff about you
you don't even realize you just you just
you you just you you will often at you
right you're laughing inside all right
now I think you know you you you just
play it for real and when you've got
these real situations in these
fascinating characters it becomes funny
so I agree with Jeremy on that like I
never actually looked and went hey we
gotta go for laughs there's no
nudge-nudge wink-wink looking at the
camera what's you ever some of the
funniest moments in the film were never
plotted as such I mean you get one of
the biggest laughs in the film which we
never anticipated when when Richie
Bradley's character apologizes to Amy
and you in the hallway after she smashed
him over the head with a glass frit your
friend says I'm sorry you're okay and he
says I'm so Kay are you okay he says
herb I'm sorry and I don't know what you
were gonna do you know and he goes it's
like I tried to imitate it it's
impossible I love it so much because he
goes you guys are twice like he's gonna
go I you can use nothing to say he's not
going to say yes or I'm also sorry it's
just like this whole situation is just
ridiculous it's like I have nothing to
say to you and I remember you made a
joke that they said should we hug it out
because Irving would not want to do that
with this man I want each one of them to
do every range you know and then I write
I write for Amy you know and I see Amy
last year at different events and I
talked her about how I want her
character to be the Rost I've ever seen
the most raw like in the curlers and
also the most the most cunning and
beautiful that I've ever seen in the
same role you know and um and telling
Bradley I want him to be from the Burrow
and I wanted to live with his mother
which is the first thing we talked about
which is always so fascinating to me you
know what's motivating him you know and
and Carmine's house I wanted to live in
basically with all those kids I mean I
loved making that home with him
and and being and my son played one of
those kids and and you know telling him
about all my favorite I try to give my
favorite stuff to everybody like the
Duke Ellington because it's personally
beloved to me and I hope it's at least
if they have to fake it at least
credibly anything but it's something
they can at least relate to I give it to
them myself so all these people have a
love for life Amy's character has a love
to to reinvent herself and she embraces
a new identity I've know I've known
people like that my whole life my
father's had friend friends from the
Bronx are like that guy from the Bronx
he looks like he's an English Lord you
know but he how does he pull that off
but I guess okay he does that you know
and he decided to do that you know
business associates of my father's so
that Amy does that and becomes British
which is a wonderful moment that that's
what I live for their love of Duke
Ellington together that they both knew
that their love of and it's for her with
Jennifer the love of the child together
and sort of a fight becomes a merit in a
marriage becomes a weird love of its own
in a weird way and and Ricci you know he
loves his fish and he loves and he loves
the idea of these two he loves joining
their theater company and training with
them and he wants to kind of just keep
advancing that aren't he loves the idea
of doing justice only to I think when he
sees through the curtain at the end you
know where we've come since then quite
frankly is that a briefcase of money is
a very quaint thing and today it's tens
or hundreds of millions of dollars that
change hands legally through the Koch
brothers or through you know any number
of legal channels and it's just beyond
even that was a much more innocent world
you know so Richie just peers behind
that curtain and I love seeing his face
at the end of the room says that's what
I was trying to do you know I mean
that's just a very real moment for me